[Music]
41
of americans make new year's goals and
resolutions
only 8 percent end up keeping them 60
already through in the towel before they
started
what and here's what we know we know
that people don't set goals because they
don't think they can hit them
right i mean eight percent
only only eight i mean that's why we
call people successes
golly they're successful yeah i mean
being able to stick to it to be able to
follow up
and i've said this a dream is a goal
without a plan it's a wish if you don't
have a plan
and so what do you want to dream yeah
you do have to dream
but you don't want to be a dreamer no no
no no which by definition is someone
that does not ever implement any
freaking hard work to do the drinking
that's right they just bump their gums
and talk about it would be nice one day
yeah like if your daughter comes home
and says i'm dating a dreamer you go oh
god they're gonna live in the basement
that yeah no they're gonna live in the
basement it's gonna work out this ain't
the one honey
this ain't the one oh yeah so i mean you
want to be
dreaming but dream needs to uh get the
clouds blown off of it and put some work
clothes on and knock things out so
i always wanted to dot dot dot okay then
this is your year
yeah okay what is it you're gonna do
and here's what we do know we do know
that we all
even though it's unpopular and
politically incorrect to talk about
winning versus losing
we all admire people who achieve
their goals we call them successes now
sometimes people
we only you know that's the tall poppy
syndrome as the australians call it
where we
stand them up only in order to knock
them down like we we want everybody to
be successful but as soon as they are we
have to do something to make sure that
they're not but uh and because some of
them are jerks but that's but you know
some people that are successes but by
and large people that are successful
have worked very very hard to get there
they've done things that other people
wouldn't do
so i mean if you want to throw a
football like peyton manning if you want
to hit a golf ball
you know like rory or tiger right it
requires hitting that swinging that club
until your hands bleed
it's not like you go out there three
hours on saturday and go up there it is
i'm just a natural
you know it requires freaking work right
it really does
so you know it's you and
and yet people want to say oh well he
didn't earn that or she didn't earn that
that's not really any of your business
to start with but let's work on you
how can you be successful and it is by
setting goals it really is
and dave you know i have been here a
part of this company have gone on 16
years
and goals is a topic we've taught on a
lot especially inside of entre
leadership
where we're working with business owners
business leaders
people that are helping other people
achieve
and so a part of that we have found that
there are five things that your goals
need to be
number one specific you've got to be
clearly drawn in
into what it is you're wanting to
accomplish and you need to be very
specific number two
it needs to be measurable you need to
look to see am i making progress toward
this or am i not
right and so i want to lose weight not
good enough
no because that is measurable but it's
not specific
right i want to lose 30 pounds ah now we
have measurable that's right we have the
first two yeah and we have specific
okay i want to make more money won't
work no
how much more yeah measurable
and specific i want to make a hundred
thousand dollars when over 15 years or
this year what what's your goal what
you're aiming at
that's right and then it brings the next
thing in which dave's talking about a
time limit
so you've got to have a period of time
that you're saying i'm going to achieve
this
by this so as soon as you do that the
math kicks in those three things oh
it's specific it's measurable has a time
limit i'm going to lose 30 pounds
when over 15 years right or over 15 days
probably not gonna happen or let's say
over 90 days okay if you say 30 pounds
over 90 days everybody do the math with
me right quick 10 pounds a month two and
a half pounds a week
increase your water intake increase your
sweat level at least 30 minutes a day
do some pushing ladies yeah push backs
and push ups push ups push away
quit eating the white stuff the breads
and the rices i mean we know what to do
you don't need oprah you know what to do
and you're going to go do it right and
so this is how you lose weight you eat
less you exercise more
day and so but that and
you can look at it and go after a week
i'm up five pounds instead of down two
and a half i don't think i'm heading
towards my goal
because it's measurable it's specific
and it's broken down then into
incremental
things i want to write a book okay i'm
going to do 12 chapters i'll be a
chapter a month for a year
maybe two chapters a month for six
months
you've done it you're moving and so
you've got specific measurable time
limit
in writing this was the game changer for
me
uh even back in college days our coach
would have us write down what are you
going to do in this upcoming ball game
yeah
number of tackles yeah write it down how
many tackles was your
number was the highest number tackles
you in the game oh i think 14 or 15.
did you just lie no really no no no
because i put it down and that little
man would read the goal
and if you didn't hit it you felt
accountable that means people you
you were coming over the middle as a
middle linebacker hitting somebody
i was doing things 14 15 times that
scares the crap out of me i'm just
trying to
make my heart happen it makes me it
makes me happy i'm going to scoot over
here but listen here
so the specific measurable have a time
limit in writing and this last one is
huge
it's got to be yours and as we talk
about this other people can have goals
and thoughts and my wife wants me to
lose weight
it's not going to work your dad wants
you to become a pastor oh god
ain't going to work i don't i don't want
to go to your church it's got to be
yours
and when it matters to you i'm going to
tell you something i talked to people
dave on my show about this
the secret to setting goals i want you
to identify whose wins when you win
like think about it if you get healthier
your kids win because you're better
but what are you going to sacrifice in
order to get that win you know one of my
pastors did the opposite he's got
written in the front of his bible
who would be negatively affected if he
ever fell
in the front of his bible he reads that
every day ooh the number of lives i
would destroy
if i make bad decisions and this is the
opposite this is if i make good
decisions
i can change my family tree that's right
i can give to this charity
i can give to this ministry i can grow a
business and
give people jobs i can if i win this is
what happens yeah
and yeah that write down who's gonna who
who's gonna be affected when you win
that's powerful no it does and it
changes the mindset around it
and uh it's really important and dave i
know you've also been around zigg for
many years
i had an opportunity to meet him through
you uh that man was a game changer but
uh he talks about seven areas
uh that we call the wheel of life
financial goals intellectual goals
family goals spiritual goals physical
goals career goals and social goals
and they are all uh intermingled hmm
you can't just you know if you win it
finances and lose your family you missed
it
if you win at family and you're all
broke because you never work but
everybody's really nurtured
then um that's probably not a good plan
either right and
so i mean if you win at your work and
your family but you let your
physique get completely out of control
right then you've lost i mean so these
things are intermingled spiritual goals
hey
america watson every year hey dave which
area gives you the most challenge and
then the seven
social sharon says if i wasn't married
to her i wouldn't have friends
that's not true you just would have i
said she said it i didn't say it's true
there you go it's been the same for 16
years it just makes my heart happy to
ask him
yeah but you coming across the middle 14
times and a dadgum game scares the crap
out of me i'm just saying
all right folks set some goals specific
measurable have a time limit and in
writing and most importantly they need
to be your goals
this is the dave ramsey show